outch nous allons beaucoup vous parler
du sida dès aujourd'hui et durant le
week end
c'est le rôle du sidaction tout en
faisant appel à vos dons en 2005 et
l'inquiétude l'emportent de nouveau en
france particulièrement
en guyane le département le plus touché
avec une moyenne de 40 aura cas pour
100000 habitants
la contamination des jeunes femmes
enceintes frôle les 2 % un chiffre
comparable à la prime
sur le terrain les associations se
battent avec leurs moyens pour faire
passer le message de prévention la lutte
contre le sida aux portes du village sur
les stands pour que l'information n'ait
plus de barrières sociales durant près
de trois heures des bénévoles vont
distribuer des préservatifs et informer
la population dans ce quartier de céder
sa mère les bénévoles vont sillonner le
quartier
objectif sensibiliser la population sur
les moyens de prévention
un moment fort lors de la soirée le
débat sans tabou restaurée entre le
médecin et les prostituées
en réalité le les personnes qui sont
plus à risque sont les vagues avant ou
les vagabonde sexuelle qui
beaucoup de partenaires occasionnels
multiples chances beaucoup de
partenaires et qui ne se protègent pas
parce que dans une inconscience totale
du prologue
face à l'ampleur de la maladie faciliter
l'accès à l'information est un devoir un
droit dont sont privés les populations
silencieuse des quartiers insalubres
l'initiative de l'association entraide a
permis aux exclus les stands une soirée
de se sentir tout simplement impliqués
dans cette lutte mondiale contre le sida